think about san francisco in the late
60s and images like this might appear in
your head
the summer of love hippies timothy leary
the grateful dead and explosion of youth
culture
chinatown never makes that highlight
real and yet three miles due east from
hate street a transformation was
happening
centered around a pool hall founded by
american-born chinese gangsters
and a japanese-american gang member from
oakland they called it leeways
short for legitimate ways and the
mission was to find employment and
recreation for the youth of our
community
gangs like the raiders the immortals
abc's and fobs passed through
played pool and pinball danced bought
and sold drugs guns and fireworks
smoked grass dropped acid fell in love
raised kids built community
and tried to change the world leeway's
tried to do what had never been done
before
and now with society and politics so
polarized and divisive
chinatown and its wisdom and its lessons
so long hidden from view
should be shared so this is a love story
about chinatown its past and what that
pass could mean for its future
many of these photos by my friend jerry
jew have never been seen before
the negatives stashed away in shoeboxes
for nearly 60 years
thank you jerry for trusting me with
them
now this is not a one of jerry's
pictures
he's old but not that old these are
chinatown gangster circa 1892 when
chinatown was 90
men railroad laundry and factory workers
who couldn't vote
own land or marry outside their race 42
years later bruce lee born three blocks
away
managed to do all three before passing
in 73
eight years after the 1882 chinese
exclusion act was finally repealed and a
new wave of chinese arrived in chinatown
forming their own gangs
like peter from the watching and the joe
louis boys
leeways was about transcending beef
happening on the streets
bands of chinese whites and blacks
filled portsmouth square with the sound
of rock and roll and motown
songs like you're still a young man
suavecito
and i can't get next to you this was a
time when making out and parked cars in
broad daylight was cool to figure out
who you are and what you really wanted
to be
in america your answers ancestors have
always felt
a tenuous love for a land they embraced
but rarely kissed them back
while back in the mainland mao's
cultural revolution annihilated
thousand-year-old norms while
girlfriends of watching gangsters fall
into the center of a women's rights
movement
and america's own brand of revolution i
think of stories like my buddy
derek quan derek saw this picture of
himself
he said my father cq was a notorious
gangster and leeway's member
he passed in 98 and mom's not talking
but i do believe i was conceived
on top of that that pinball uh pinball
machine at leeway's
sometimes cq would get high pour me into
the 58 chevy around midnight
rumble six blocks to the bottom of
lombard peel out burning rubber and
sliding no seat belt
up the wrong way of that one crooked
street laughing
and it was moments like this i knew he
was truly happy
asians have a long history of swimming
upstream against the current in america
going the wrong way up lombard a
rebellion defiance against a system that
for centuries
wanted asian hands for labor but not our
rights for equal treatment
listen the truth is san francisco
chinatown isn't even supposed to be here
after the 1906 earthquake city hall
tried to move chinatown to hunter's
point
chinatown found ways to stay
transforming into a tourist destination
and this pandemic means chinatown must
reinvent itself again
and i believe the spirit of leeways is
exactly what is needed
when the so-called model minority
experimented with marijuana and orange
sunshine
redefined traditional roles and dream
dreams bigger than any generation before
them
i think of 1969 in the movie easy rider
the desire it must have sparked
expansive boundless potential to venture
beyond chinatown's borders
aspirations so mind-blowingly different
than what their parents could imagine
while hollywood's mr yoshida in
breakfast and tiffany's
charlie chan cato the house boy the
cooley stereotypes of asian man
shattered by bruce lee and jerry's
pictures
even in 2020 these dudes still look like
the badass as they were
and still are today think of all this
change and the speed of it
how discombobulating this must have felt
to their parents and grandparents who
wanted to leave revolution behind
not have their children to be part of
igniting a perilous new one
leeways eventually became radicalized
factionalized a red guard movement
drawing the eyes of the fbi and the
wrath of chinatown six companies
sfpd raids on leeways eventually closed
it down forever
there are lessons here too but i'm
telling you
things are bubbling in chinatown now
again under the surface
the old folks you pass on chinatown
streets may be the kids in jerry's
photos
now just older and wiser versions they
remember
they still all have a dream for
chinatown
to rise again thank you